Hi everyone, I am back
again, and I am excited
to be giving you all
another great lecture.
Today I have the
honor of presenting
you all another DPR lecture.
Today we're going to be
talking about the history
and the physical exam of
the ankle and the foot.
This is going to be my
final lecture for you
all, so I hope you all
enjoyed these lectures
as much as I enjoyed
presenting them. I wish
you the best of luck
for the rest of first
year, second year, and
everything and beyond.
And remember to take some
time this summer, right,
by the time you're actually
watching the lectures,
right, it's probably
about a month or two
away from summertime.
So enjoy your summer,
right, and if you have
any questions about the
lecture or anything in
general, you can always contact
me at mheller.nyit.edu.
That's my email address.
If you notice, I got rid
of Larry the Bird, right?
So again, my email is
here. Any questions,
comments, concerns,
or if you just
want to say hi,
feel free to say hi.
And please make sure you
leave some comments on
the lecture survey that
presents is at the end of
your presentation, we'll
move on with the lecture.
And so today's objective
is basically we're
going to talk about
the history taking and
the physical exam of
the ankle and the foot.
We're going to describe
the subjective, remember
the subjective is
everything the patient tells
you and the objective is
going to be your finding
on physical exam of
the ankle and the foot.
We're going to distinguish
normal and then we're
going talk about abnormal
findings. We're going
to talk about the
appropriate ways to document
and common normal and
abnormal findings, and
we're going to incorporate
OMM into a case study.
When I did my
fellowship in sports
medicine, I did it
down at Campbell,
Campbell University School of
Osteopathic Medicine, QSOM.
So with the Division I
athletes, a lot of the
athletes were coming
in for OMM. When I came
into New York Tech, we
had an athletic program.
We did a lot of OMM,
and OMM actually
reduced the amount of
time that they had to
take off, and they
were able to get back
into the game quicker
and more efficient.
So we will talk about
OMM into the case study.
So what we're going to
talk about today, again, I
mentioned we're going to talk
today about the ankle and
the foot. So that's basically
not everything above
the knee, but it's basically
everything below knee.
Again, we are the
Red Wolves and the
Bears, so hello,
Dan and Johnville.
I hope you are all
doing well. Hello
up in Long Island,
New York, Red.
We'll do a quick roll call,
right? So if you are, let
me get my pointer out.
So if you are a Red Wolve
and you're studying in the
library or wherever you may
be, let's here you howl.
And if you're up in New
York, if you're in one
of the new Student Mounds
studying or the library
or one of the many
other places that they
have on campus now to
study, which here you are.
So here's a cool picture
I'm pulling back on my pen.
So So my biggest advice
for you all is to
stay active, whether
it's getting warmer,
stay active, hang out
with your colleagues.
Because, believe it or not,
all your classmates now
are going to be your colleagues
in the next few years.
So you may not know now,
but everybody that you're
working with are people
that are going to go
into different specialties,
working at different
hospitals, and they're
going to be the colleagues
that you rely on if you
ever need assistance.
So, this is from me
from the class of 2011,
so we had a solid
basketball team.
Every one of these
players went on to
different specialties,
very, very successful,
and anesthesiology.
This guy over here
is the team doc for
University of Miami.
So University of Miami
had a great year in
the final four a few
years back. He got to be
a team doc. He is a team
doc for the University
of Miami. And then
we have a few others,
anesthesiology, PM&R,
emergency medicine,
family medicine, neurology.
And I would just kind of
correlate that. You know what,
12 years later, I'm
playing again with
the next graduating
class of the school.
So again, my biggest
advice for you all, stay
active. This is actually
me, about maybe five hours
before I recorded this
lecture, so I did get my
run-ins, so this is
softball when we won our
championship this past year.
We won against, this is
actually the fire department,
so dick's Hill fire
versus the Merylville fire
department, and this is
the class of 25, some of
them may look familiar,
these are your former
academic scholars actually.
These were the academic
scholars that were
the year before the
current academic scholars.
So again, I only put
these pictures up,
reminds you to stay
active and have some fun.
So definitely these are
Class of 25 members.
And these are some of your
favorite faculty members.
So these are your favorite
people right here.
So we try to make it fun,
even with the presentation
and the lectures, we
try to make it fun.
So how about that
Jeopardy game? If you guys
enjoyed the Jeopardy
game, I hope you did.
These are the Class
of 2024, and they
definitely enjoyed
putting it together.
It took a lot of time,
but it was definitely
worth it at the end. So
if you enjoyed it again,
feel free to leave some
comments, leave some
feedback, give us some
ideas what we can do to make
it better, what we can
do to make it more fun.
This way it kind of
helps the lecturers
and helps you retain
the information.
So we're going to go
back to talking about
the ankle and the foot,
and that's what our
topic is today, history
and physical exam.
So it's important to know a
little bit about
the background.
So things that we want to know
is when we obtain the history,
we want to know what kind of
injury that they're sustaining,
and that goes part of
the mechanism of injury.
So we need to keep in
mind some of the basic
biomechanics that goes
along with it. So we need to
know that the ankle and
the foot basically carry
the total weight of the
body and all that weight
is transmitted through
the ankle to the foot.
We must balance
the body and absorb
the impact of the heel strike.
And it's usually
an area where we're
going to get a lot
of sprains. You're
of bony injuries.
You can get a lot
of overuse injuries.
If somebody that's
not used to running
and now they're
training for a marathon,
they might be going up too
quick as far as mileage.
They might be
going up too quick,
and they might be
going up too much.
Again, you get a lot
of sprains. We see
it all the time, people
roll their ankles,
they jump, they land,
they're running,
they trip, whatever
it might be.
So it's an area that
frequently gets injured.
So known as the
principal joint of the
ankle, we have the
tibial talus joint.
So this is basically
a hinge joint. This
is a hinge joint that
occurs between the
talus and the medial
malleolus of the tibia.
and the lateral
malleolus of the fibular.
And the main function
of this is for ankle
dorsiflexion and for ankle
plantar flexion, right?
So ankle dorsiflexion coming up
and plantar flexion going down.
We also have the subtalar
joint. The subtalar
joint is basically more
of a shock absorber,
right? So it's a
shock absorber, and it
also allows internal
-external rotation of the
leg when the foot is
in a fixed position.
Some landmarks,
very, very prominent.
You should be able
to palpate it, unless
they have severe
swelling, a lot of pain.
But you have the medial
malleolus, you have the
lateral malleolus, and
you have the calcaneus.
Calcaneus, layman terminology.
It's always good to know
the layman terminology,
so when you're talking
to the patient,
A lot of people will
call that the heel bone.
Then underneath the foot,
you have the longitudinal
arc, this spans the
foot extending from the
calcaneus along the tarsal
bone to the metatarsal and
the toes, and then you
have the sub-tallus joint.
You have the hind
foot, which is made
up, so this is in the posterior
aspect of the calcaneus
and the talus.
This contains the
subtala, so you have the
talus, and then you
have the subtala joint
that's formed by
articulation of these bones,
of the calcaneus and
the talus. You have the
hind foot, and then
you have the mids foot.
The mids foot is going to
be your navicular bone,
the cuboid, and the
three corneiform bone.
And then you have a few
other joints, minor joints,
I'm not going to test these
on these minor joints,
but they're good to know
that they do allow for
other functions of the foot
to occur. So whether it's
the calcaneal cuboid or
the tallow, calcaneal,
navicular joint, that allows
inversion and eversion.
Again, I'm not going to be
very specific with these
specific joints, but it's
good to know that they're
there and to know that
they do have a function.
And then we get to the
forfeit. The forfeit is
basically made up of the five
metatarsal bone and all of
the phalensis. You have
the tarsal, metatarsal
joint, right, so the tarsal,
metatarsal joint is formed
between the medial, middle,
and lateral cuneiform
bone, the cuboid bone,
and the metatarsal. That's
the junction between the
midspert and the forefoot.
You have the five metatarsal
that articulate with
the five proximal phalensias,
right, and that gives
you your metatarsal
phalensial joint, right. So
again, this is a very big
word, but if you break it
up, it makes sense, right?
Metatarsal and felinzio,
right?
So it's just a joint
that's made up of the
metatarsal and the
felinzio, right? The toes of
two to five, remember,
had the PIP and the DIP,
and the first toe,
you don't have a DIP,
PIP, so they're going
to call it the IP,
interphalangeal joint.
So again these basically
joints allow for flexion
and extension of the toes
and they have ligament
that attaches to them as
well that can become injured
and that we have to keep
in our differential.
Just a diagram a little bit
of what we talked about,
right? So remember that
the deltoid ligament is on
the medial side. We talked
about that in the other
lecture. And then if you're
looking at the lateral
side, you have the three
commonly injured ligaments,
right, the ATFL, or
which one first ligament,
or it's always one first,
but the name of the
ligament is anterior
tallofibular ligament. You
have the calcaneofibular
ligament, and then you
have the posterior
tallofibular ligament. And
then a lot of this
stuff is basically
what we talked about
on the prior slide.
Something to keep in mind
when you're palpating,
right, it's good
to know where the
landmarks are, right? So
right here, for example,
we have the base of
the fifth metatarsal,
right? If you're palpating
along the base of the
fifth metatarsal, and
now they have pain right
here, right? You got to
think of your anatomy or what
the injury could be,
right? So it could be the
bone, right? Where you
have an injury to the base
of the fifth metatarsal,
and that might be related
to a Jones fracture,
right, J-O-N-E-S-E, J-O-N,
oops, I spelled it wrong,
so it's Jones fracture,
J-O-N-E-S, Jones fracture
versus a tendon that
attaches to it, right, which
is the peroneic brevis.
And then not only do
you have the bones, but
you have the muscles,
not only do you have and
ligaments, but you also
have muscles that make
up the foot and ankle,
right. So the extrinsic
and you have the
intrinsic, right. So the
extrinsic is going to be
made up of a compartment,
right. So extrinsic muscle
originates outside the
other foot and the ankle,
right, where intrinsic is
actually going to be inside
the other foot and ankle,
right. But the extrinsic
is going to be made up of a
compartment, right. So you
have the anterior compartment
of the lower leg. So think
about what's on the anterior
side, what's on the front,
and those are going to
be your ankle dorsiflexors
and your toes extensors.
So you have the tibialic
anterior that causes
dorsiflexion of the ankle,
the tibialic anterior
that causes dorsiflexion
of the ankle, you
have the extensor,
there's a two-arm longus,
extension of toes
two to five, and then
you have the extensor
holisus longus,
which is the extension
of the first toe.
You also have the posterior
aspects, right? The
posterior aspects are
going to be your gastroc
muscles, the soleus muscles,
your plantarous muscles,
right? These are going
to be your ankle plantar
flexions, right? So
the gastroc muscle is
easily, very easily palpated
at the posterior lower
leg with the origin at
the lateral and the medial
femoral condyle, right,
and that's going to
insert onto the calcaneus
via the Achilles tendon.
The gastroc, you know, is
a secondary knee flexor,
and it's also, it's a
secondary knee flexor, right,
it's also going to plantar
flex the other foot when
you extend the knee. So
when you extend the knee,
it's going to help you
plantar flex the other foot.
The soleus muscle is deeper
to the gastroc muscle,
but it's in the same
compartment, So when you're
palpating, you're more likely
going to be palpating the
gastroc, the soleus is going
to be right underneath.
The toe flexors, the
toe flexors are going
to be your deep
posterior compartment.
So we have your
superficial posterior and
you have your deep
posterior compartment.
The flexor hallucis, longus,
ensures that the first
distal phalanx and that's
going to allow you to flex.
It's going to allow you to
flex your big toe and then
your medial to the flexor
hallucinous longus is going
to be your flexor digitorum
longus, right, and those
are going to insert at the
phalanges of the toe two
to five. I'm not going
to be very detailed with
these, but it's good to know
on the compartment, right.
Tibialic posture is
the most medial to the
muscles, most medial of the
muscles and that's insert
onto the navicular
criniform and the cuboid.
On the extrinsic, we
also talked about the
we talked about the
anterior and posterior. The
lateral compartment is
very important to know,
right? The peroneus longest
and the brevis, right? I
mentioned before when you're
palpating in the base of
the fifth metatarsal, is
it really an injury at the
at the base of the fifth
metatarsal? Is it a bone
injury or is it going to
be a tendon injury, right?
Knowing your anatomy, knowing
that the peroneus revist
attaches to the base of the
fifth metatarsal is going
to give you a very clear,
a very good indicator that
maybe it's a tendon injury,
maybe it's a bone injury.
Then you also have the
peroneus longus, right, that's
going to go underneath
and that's going to attach
to the medial cuneiform
and the first metatarsal.
That's pretty much for
the extrinsic, right?
Oh yeah, and the
function of the lateral
compartment is the
foot eversion and it
provides a little bit
of plantar flexion.
So the intrinsic muscles
distal to the ankle
within the plantar surface
of the foot and it allows
additional movements
of the toes and maintain
the arc of the foot.
So when you're getting a
history taking, it's very
important to go through
your PQRST. When did
the pain begin? You want
to know, Is it something
that's acute or is it
something that is chronic?
A lot of time the
history and the mechanism
and the actual injury
can give you a good
clue to what the
pathology is going to be.
You want to know if
they have any history of
hip and knee pain because
sometimes the body can
compensate and it causes
a dysfunction in the
hip or knee that causes
the body to compensate.
right and now you're
going to put more
stress on the lower on
the lower extremity.
Ask about the nature
of the circumstance
of the injury. What
were you doing at the
time? Did you feel
pain? Did you feel
something pop? Did you
feel something snap?
What was the foot position
when you hurt yourself?
Did your ankle
come in or did it
go out? Did it
turn the wrong way?
Maybe there was a
weight that fell on top
of it when it was in
an awkward position.
It might be like a
left flank injury
where you get that
posterior force
that comes down
against the calcaneus.
Immediate pain, what
happened right after the
injury? What did you do
for the pain? What did you
do for the swelling? And
this is a great question
right here. I always love
having the patient say,
just say that I'm pointing
to the pain, and let
the patient point exactly
to where the pain is.
That's going to help
you determine the exact
location, and OP,
QRSC, make sure you get
a good detail of what
do they do for the
pain, if they haven't
done anything for it.
Quality, radiation,
severity, timing.
Okay, so we mentioned
that the foot and
the ankle are weight
-bearing structures.
So as such, they're
going to be prone
to getting stress
injuries from activity
that exposes them
to repeat stress,
right? So what causes
repeat stress, for example,
they're running, right?
They are running,
and they're running too
much, or they're running
too, or they increase
too much, too soon,
right, so now they're
going to have potentially
an overuse injury, right,
so you want to know
if this is something that
was chronic, that they
had pain before, and
maybe they didn't let it
fully heal, and now
they're having pain again,
right, you want to
know how much activity
the patient is performing
in a day, right, so
it's not a UOP CRS,
but you can add the
pace, and how many miles
are you running now,
right, how many
miles have you been
running last week,
and the week before,
how much are you
progressing over time?
And you want to know are
they competing, what their
goals are, right? Are they
training for a marathon,
are they training for a
heifer marathon, are they
training for an ultramarathon,
or are they just running
because they want to
compete in something else?
You want to know what
kind of shoes that they're
wearing, right? And how long
they've been using them,
right? And again,
progression of the pain.
So when we do the
examination right that's your
history taken now the
examination right the easiest
thing to do is just see
how the patient is working
right um just have the
patient if you don't get to
see them walk from the
waiting room to the to the uh
to the room right then
you could always have the
patient walk into the hallway
right tell the patient
we can bring a patient
into the hallway tell them
walk to the end walk back
and just kind of take a
look at how they're how
they are carrying themselves
When you do the exam,
shoes and socks should
be removed, that's
where you could be
able to do an inspection,
right, inspection,
you're looking for
swelling, erythema,
ecchymosis, right,
erythema is redness,
ecchymosis is bruising
around the foot and ankle.
You want to be able to take
a look at the landmark,
right, you want to be able to
see the landmark. You should
be able to see the lateral
malleolus, right, the
medial malleolus, you want
to look at the skin for any
kind of lesions, and sometimes
skin lesions is going to
tell you that maybe something
else is wrong, right?
For example, if somebody has
blisters or ingrown toenails
or any distal toe
discolorations, now you might be
thinking that they have poor
fittings in their shoes.
Look at the shoes and
look at the wear pattern,
right? Sometimes you
could look underneath the
shoes and be able to see
what kind of, are they
pronating too much? Are
they under-pronating? Are
they supinating too much
when they're running?
So here is a good slide
where you can kind of see
underprenation or basically
are they supination,
right? So for example,
this person right here,
right, they're putting
too much pressure on
the inside, right? They're
overprenating. Right
here, you have the
patient, they're putting
too much pressure on
the outside of the foot,
right? So you can
kind of see that over
here is that if
they're overprenating,
right, they're going
to be putting a
lot more pressure,
right, on the inside,
right? Where if they're under
-pronating or
they're supinating,
right, they're going
to be putting more
pressure on the lateral
portion of the foot,
right? And that's
basically, you can see
that from the shoe
pattern if they've
been wearing it for
too long of a time.
And again, correction,
mechanic, right, things
you can do to help them
out so that they're
not putting the pressure
where it needs to go.
And it's going to give
you a clue to what type
of injury. Because if
they're putting too much
pressure on the inside,
the rest of the outside,
you worry about bone,
you worry about stress
fractures and other
pathologies that can develop.
So after you inspect,
you're going to palpate.
So you're going to
palpate just below the
knee, so just below the
knee, below the knee,
along the entire length
of the lower leg.
So you're going to palpate
the proximal fibular.
Remember we talked about
Why are we doing the
proximal fibula is because if
they have a high ankle sprain,
a lot of that force goes
right up to syndromes,
right into the knee joint.
So again, you're going
to do the physical exam,
you're going to palpate
from the proximal fibula
or just below the knee,
you're going to go all the
way down to the ankle,
you're going to palpate
bones, you're going to
palpate ligament, and you're
going to check for
tenderness and instability.
These are just some of the
landmarks. Again, we're
going to practice more when
we get into the DPR lab.
I think that's in April,
but when we get to the
DPR lab, we'll palpate,
we'll go more into the
landmarks. But when
we do the palpation,
everything is bilateral,
and everything is on skin.
We're using the finger pad
or the thumb for palpations.
You want to be able to palpate
the small bones
and the ligaments.
You want to be able to
palpate the Achilles tendon.
palpate and find out
if there's tendinous and
where the tendinous is.
After palpating comes
range of motion.
So active and then
passive, it should be equal
bilaterally, that's why
we do it on both sides
and we want to record
everything in degrees.
So range of motion, testing
really the different
muscles that function to
allow the range of motion.
All right, so we ask the
patients to ankle flex,
right, that's a fancy way
of saying plantar flexion,
right, so basically what
muscles are you thinking
of, you're thinking of
the gastroc, the soleus
muscles, and the plantaris,
right, and basically you're
going to say in layman
terminology, because you
say plantar flex, right,
patients will not know
what you're talking about
if they're not in the
medical field, right, your
partner in DPR lab is going
to know exactly what
you're saying, right, but
patients that's not in
medical field, you got to
use layman terminology.
Layman terminology is going
to be pointing your foot
down towards the floor,
right, ankle extension,
dorthy flexion,
right, now we have
the tibialic anterior,
the extender, visitorum,
longus, extender,
hallucis, longus, right,
so you can tell the
patient, point your foot
towards the ceiling.
Inversion, right, tibialic,
posterior, and anterior,
bend your heel inwards,
and inversion is peroneus,
longus, and brevis,
Peronius, longus and brevis,
bend your heel outward.
So range of motion, so
we talk about the ankle.
Also on the foot
exam, the forefoot,
you're going to do
inversion and eversion.
So here on the ankle
inversion, the one hand is
going to be on the
distal tibia, and the The
other hand is going to
be underneath, so on the
forefoot inversion, one
hand is going to be on the
distal tibia, and the
other hand is going to
grab the forefoot medially,
and you're going to
use this hand right here
to create an inversion,
and here it's just the
opposite. Here you're
going to create an eversion
versus an inversion.
And then the ankle, same
thing, you're going to,
for ankle inversion, you're
going to place one hand
on the patient's distal
tibia, and the other
hand is going to be
underneath the heel. So you're
going to do that on both
inversion and eversion.
And the only difference
is, one is going to go
creating a, one is going
to bring the heel inwards,
that's your inversion, and
one is going to bring your
heel outwards, and that's
going to be your eversion.
So here's a better picture
of what we're trying
to do. We're trying to
plantar flex, dorsiflex.
Eversion, bring
your heel outwards.
And inversion, you can
bring your heel inwards.
Plantar flexing of the ankle.
So for strength testing,
So we want to strength
test plantar flexion, so
you're going to put one
hand underneath the foot
and you're going to have
the patient push down.
You can tell them you're
pushing down on the gas
pedal, just have them
push down and that's going
to strength test for
plantar flexion. And then
for dorsal flexion, one
hand on the dorsal aspect
of the foot and the other
is on the lower leg.
And you're going to
instruct the patient
to push their foot
up against your hand.
The anterior draw
test. We're going to
get into some of our
special testing now.
So the anterior draw test
is basically the patient
is going to have their foot
off the table. You're going
to grab underneath the
heel and the other hand is
going to be on the tibia.
So one hand on the tibia,
one hand underneath the
heel, and you're going
to create a posterior
to anterior motion.
Posterior, meaning from
down here, and that's the
motion that you're going
to have, right? And that's
going to test for the
anterior talofibular ligament
integrity, right? So, again,
if they don't have any
endpoint or if there's
increased laxity, that's why
we do it on both sides. If
they have increased laxity,
then we will have to think
that there might be an
ATFL injury, anterior
talofibular ligament injury,
right? This can
happen with a mild
sprain with pain, if
they only have pain,
not so much laxity. So
if they have no laxity
but they just have
pain, you might think
there's a mild sprain, but
if they do have laxity,
you might think that
there might be a tear
or any kind of disruption
in the ligament.
The lateral ankle stability
test, same position
as the anterior jaw,
but the only difference
is now you're creating
an inversion. So the
talus is inverted and
you're testing out the
range of motion.
Two ways to do it,
you got the patient
laying down.
Here the patient laying
down, you're going
to have the patient
sitting up. So if the
patient is sitting up,
both ways you're going
to be creating an
inversion type of motion.
Inversion type of motion.
And here you're going to
be testing out the anterior
talofibro ligament and
you can also be testing
out the calcaneal fibrillar
ligament as well right
again you're looking for
laxity you're looking for
pain you're looking for
an increased range of
motion uh and this is all in
comparison to the other
side so don't just do it on
one side even um in real
life we do it on both
sides and um in in the ice
in the um in the sim lab
right when you guys are
demonstrating right all we
get used to doing this
bilaterally this way you can
get a feel for what's
normal and what is abnormal
We talk about the eversion
test, right, so very
similar to what we saw
before, right, but now
instead of inversion,
you're creating eversion,
right.
So the foot is eversion
against the range
of motion, and that's
going to be testing
more specifically for
the deltoid ligament.
Again, you're looking
for laxity, and you're
looking for increased
range of motion.
But if they say, Doc,
it's only hurt, it's pain,
right, but there's no
increased laxity, then
you might think, okay,
maybe it's a mild sprain.
So again, the motion is
creating an inversion,
right, so you're
coming out this way. We
have the external rotation
test, right, external rotation
test, I think we mentioned
in one of the orthopedic
lectures, right, external
rotation, so basically
you're stabilizing the lower
leg, right, this leg is being
stabilized, and you're putting
your hand on the dorsum
of the of the dorsum of
the foot and you are going
to externally rotate it
right so the hand is going to
externally rotate the foot
and if there is pain along
the syndesmosis or medial
ankle that could be significant
for pathology right so if
they have pain along the
syndesmosis right you might
think that there might be
a high ankle sprain right
they have a pain along the
a medial ankle, right,
you might think that they
have a deltoid ligament,
right, so depending on
where the pain is, so let
the patient tell you where
the pain is, right, if
they say doc, it hurts,
right, you can ask them,
where does it hurt, and if
they need to point to the
pain, they can point to
the pain as well, right,
and that's going to help
differentiate whether it's
from the deltoid, whether
it's from the high ankle,
or at a synoptimosis.
Then we also have a very
simple test, very commonly
done, this is the syndesmosis
or the squeeze test.
Basically, you place the
senile eminence of one hand
on the tibial, and you
take the senile eminence of
the other hand on the
fibula, and you just squeeze
it for two to three seconds,
and then you quickly
release it. If they have
pain, you're thinking about a
syndesmosis injury. So here,
we are putting pressure
on both sides, and if they
have increased pain, that's
what makes the high ankle
sprain so hard to treat
sometimes, because with
the lower ankle sprain,
sometimes you can just wrap
it up, you can compress,
we're talking about rest eye
compressing, you can wrap
it up, but even with like
Patrick Mahomes, when he
has a high ankle sprain
and they run him into the
training room, it's hard
to kind of just wrap it up,
because what are they
doing, they're putting more
pressure on it, they're
compressing it, that's going to
create more pain. Because
the injury is right here.
It's basically involving
the syndicinosis.
We have the Thompson test.
So Thompson, I
mentioned before, and
in O-N. So Thompson,
and in O-N, and
that's going to be
your Achilles tendon.
So again, O-N over here,
O-N over here. Because
everybody loves to mix it
up, Thomas and Thompson.
So when we talk about
Thomas test, we talked
about that with the hip,
we talked about Thomas.
So Thomas ends in A
-S, and so does Psoez.
Did I get that right?
I think I did.
I got the spelling right.
S-P-S-O-A-S, right, so
psoas, right, and then A
-S, Thomas, and then A-S,
right, Thompson,
and then O-N, Achilles
tendon, and then O-N, right,
it's going to, they're going
to try to trick you up,
right, I remember they, they
do that, I don't know why,
but they try to trick you
up, so we want to make sure
that we know Thompson, and
then O-N, Achilles tendon,
right, and basically
what you're doing,
you're squeezing
the calf muscle,
right, so you're
going to squeeze the
gastroc muscle,
you're going to look
for a plantar
flexion of the ankle.
And that's going to
check for Achilles
tendon rupture. If
there's no plantar flexion
at all, then we know
we have an injury.
But this exam that
I'm doing right here,
not even a lot of force.
I'm just squeezing the
gastroc, I'm squeezing
the gastroc, and you can
see that the foot is
coming up into plantar
flexion. Because when you
squeeze, it's pulling on
tendon, the Achilles
tendon, and that's going to
cause the foot to go
into the plantar flexion.
So again, Thompson tendon,
Thomas AS, Psoez AS.
Tibial chalice shock
chest, cotton chest,
a lot of these chests
have multiple names.
Examination, basically
you're going to stabilize
the hand at the lower leg,
and then your hand is going
to grab the chalice
underneath, and it's going
to move it medial to lateral.
So here I'm just moving
it medial to lateral,
right, and I'm looking for
any kind of pain or laxity,
right? I'm looking for
pain, I'm looking for
laxity, right, on the non
-infected side, and that's
going to be significant for
a chin dysmosis or a
disrupting injury or a high
ankle sprain, right? And
then if you think that the
patient's leg might be
unequal in length, right,
it's not a bad idea to
measure them, right? You can
get the patient in a
relaxed, supine position It's
a two-prime position,
right, and you're going to
symmetrically align with
the legs extended. You don't
have to pace them right
down with the legs extended.
With a tape, measure
the distance from the
ASIS, right, ASIS, to
the medial malleolus.
Right, so ASIS, medial
malleolus, the tape
should correct the knee
on the medial side.
If they have equal
length, right,
but they're different
height, right,
so equal length of the
of the leg but they have
different height right
that's going to tell you that
maybe they have a pelvic
rotation an anonymous rotation
and if they have unequal
length right you might
think okay maybe they have
scoliosis right so these
are the things to keep in
mind as you're doing the
testing right um and
then the osteopathic um
evaluation as well right so
you're looking for any kind
of dysfunction you're
looking for lymphatic you're
looking for any kind of
restriction And if you find
the somatic dysfunction,
you're going to treat it.
So the osteopathic
exam should be
incorporated into this as well.
You want to make sure you
do a neurovascular exam.
So remember we talked about the
deep tendon reflexes,
the sensation,
and the vascular.
So deep tendon
reflexes, remember
L4, kick the door.
right, so L4,
and you have the
door right there,
right,
L4 is going to kick the door.
Nothing for L5, and then
S1 is going to be your
Achilles tendon reflex,
right, sensory, just
remember L4, L5, S1,
medial to the dorsal to the
lateral foot, and the
vascular, right, you're going
to detect the pulses at
the dorsal pedis and the
posterior tibialis, and
we're to practice that in
lab, right, so you get
a good sense for being
able to check it bilaterally
and to know whether
you have normal pulses or
whether it's decreased.
Condition of injuries,
right, these are common
conditions that can
happen from injuries.
You're going to have
a lateral or medial
ankle strain, right,
because you have a lot
of tendons, you can get
a tendonitis, because
you have muscles,
you can get a strain,
you have the plantar
fascia that could become
inflamed, you're
going to have chronic
exertional compartment
syndrome. We talked
a lot about that in
the orthopedic lecture.
Usually this requires
the athlete to stop
running and usually
the most commonly you
can get that anterior
compartment syndrome.
And MTSS, right,
so medial tibial
stress syndrome,
right, very, very fancy
word of way of
saying shin splints.
So we have the Achilles
tendonitis, right,
we have the Achilles
tendon rupture, right,
and we're going to
have the ankle sprain.
We talked about Colby
Bryant and his Achilles
tendon rupture, right,
we could name almost
any athletes and we could
say that they probably
had an ankle sprain
at some point, right.
And then the Achilles
tendonitis basically
inflames information
at the insertion of the
calcaneal tuberosity,
right, because that's
where the muscles are
going, into the tendon.
So speaking of Achilles
tendonitis, it's going
to occur at or above
the Achilles tendon.
Microtrauma, right, at
the insertion, and the
patient's going to have
heel pain, and it's going
to get worse when they
push off, right. So if
they're going to say, you
can ask them, when does it
hurt the most, and they
say when they push off.
Treatment is going
to include rest, ice,
anti-inflammatory, exercises,
and potentially a healer.
And definitely you want to make
sure you avoid cortisone shots,
cortisone, steroids,
putting that into
the Achilles tendon,
into a weight band
structure is not
generally a good idea
because what can
happen then is going
to degrade a lot of
the tendon and increase
the risk of injuries
down the road.
So we're going to move
into a case study. We have
a 22-year-old male who
happened to be a medical
student who happened to be
given this presentation.
He was a right ankle injury.
He said that he was
playing basketball several
hours ago, and he
jumped up, landed on his
right ankle, and it's
twisted, it's inverted.
And now he has a
very painful and
swollen ankle, and
he said that he's
unable to bear weight
due to the pain.
He went to his old trainers
at NYT, who happened to
be his trainer when he
was running cross-country.
And he was given ice to put
on the ankle and advised
to come to the clinic
for further evaluations.
So again, he's a second
-year medical student.
He was supposed to be
at his genetic lecture,
but it was Friday, and
it was a very, very warm
day. And it was a really
nice day to be outdoors.
physical exam, vital
signs were good,
didn't get a weight
because I was unable to
obtain due to non
-weight-bearing status,
so it was very nice
that they said I
was a pleasant male,
I agree with that.
Mild distress secondary
to pain, so when you say
somebody's in stress, you want
to say why they're in distress,
is it because of pain or
whatever it might be, Maybe
there's difficulty breathing,
whatever it might be.
I was alert, oriented time
three, head is normal cephalic,
atraumatic.
The right ankle was
examined and compared to
the left ankle, right?
So they compared both
sides. I was unable to
bear weight secondary to
pain, right? There's no
obvious bone deformity
or dislocation. There's
no muscle malformation.
There's significant
swelling and ecumosis,
mostly along the lateral
malleolus. There's no
erythema. There's tendus
of palpation at the
lateral malleolus. No other
bone tenderness. There's
no step-off. Range of
motion is decreased in
all directions secondary
to pain. Why is there
a decrease in range of
motion? Because of pain.
Unable to perform special
testing or provocative
testing and maneuvers
secondary to the sprain.
So we come up with a
differential diagnosis.
Most commonly, it could be
a right ankle sprain right
but you want to make sure
is that you got to make sure
that um you're pretty sure
that there's no fracture
to the fibula as well um
high ankle sprain in the
differential Achilles tendonitis
ankle dislocation right
so if you go down the list
the more unlikely it's
going to be so the most
likely diagnosis is usually on
top so what was the plan
right because I was non-weight
-bearing and I had difficulty
stepping on the ankle,
but we got an x-ray. We're
going to talk a little
bit more about when to order
an x-ray in a little bit.
Right ankle was wrapped
with our 4-inch Coban tape.
We used an air cast
for stability, so
an air cast to
stabilize the ankle.
Crusties were
given in the office
and I was counseled
on how to use it.
Advise patients to
stay off the ankle
until the x-rays are
taken, good advice.
If they have a
fracture and you order
an x-ray, you want to make sure
they're not putting
some weight on it.
We talk about the advice, rest,
ice, compressing, elevation,
over-the-counter, anti
-inflammatory is needed
for the pain, plan
to follow up in the
office tomorrow morning
to review the x-ray.
So again, all your plans
should always have a follow
-up plan. right and if
possible why you want the
patient to follow up right
just to see progress of the
pain or to review the x-ray
or review the lab whatever
it might be and so I
got the x-ray done right
these are the actual x-rays
and luckily there was nothing
broken right but you
can see some evidence of
swelling so a lot of fluid
and so the ankle sprain is
the greatest risk factor
is a previous ankle sprain.
Most ankle sprains are
injury to the lateral
ligaments, right, so the
ATFL, the CFL, and that's
usually due to the inversion
of the ankle with some
degree of plantar flexion,
right? So some degree
of plantar flexion, so
whether it's a basketball
player landing the wrong
way or it's a baseball
player that's sliding
into second base or it's
something that causes an
inversion of the ankle
and potentially some
degree of plantar flexion.
Basically tenderness, swelling,
ecchymosis is very common.
And then we're going to
grade the ankle. I'm not
going to expect it in all
different grades, but the
higher the grade, the more
severe it's going to be,
right, and the longer it's
going to take the heel,
right. So a lot of the special
testing of the ligament's
integrity are difficult
to perform at the onset of
the injury. So if somebody
just hurt themselves and
you're on the sideline and
you're covering the game and
they just hurt themselves
at this moment, it might be
hard to do all the testing,
right? But you do what you
can, right? What can you
do? You can definitely
inspect, right? Look at it.
Is there swelling, bruising,
redness, whatever you see?
Is there any obvious
bone deformity, muscle
malformation? Is there obvious
that there's an injury,
right? So inspections,
you can palpate, but you
might not be able to
do all the testing, but
you could do as much as
the patient can tolerate.
Ottawa, ankle and foot rule.
I mentioned before about
one order and x-ray, and
definitely know that the
Ottawa ankle and foot rule is
a well-established clinical
guideline used to determine
the need for radiograph.
So we talked about the nexus
criteria in the other lecture,
one order and x
-ray for the neck.
Now, we're going
to talk about the
Ottawa ankle and
foot rule. When do we
order an x-ray for
the foot and ankle?
So, there's pain in
the malleolar joint
and there's either
bone tenderness
over the area of a
potential fracture.
So, they have to have
pain and they have to have
tenderness over the area
of the potential fracture.
So on the ankle, it's going
to be on the posterior
aspect of the medial or
the lateral malleolus.
And it's going
to be tenderness.
And they're going to have to
have the inability to bear
weight for four-step
immediately after the injury
and in the emergency department
or physician's office.
So that's pretty
much for the ankle.
And then for the foot
radiograph, do we get an x-ray,
they're going to have to
have pain, they have to have
pain in the mid-foot shown,
plus either bone tendinous
over the areas of potential
fracture. So that's
going to be the base of
the fifth metatarsal or the
navicular bone. So if they
have pain on the navicular
bone or if they have pain
at the base of the fifth
metatarsal and they have
tendinous there and they have
pain and they have the
inability to bear weight right
that's going to be the uh
the foot rule right so the
last one we talked about
the ankle which is very
similar but they're going
to have tenderness at the
posterior aspect of the medial
or the lateral malleolus
uh the high ankle sprain
right high ankle sprain
right we talked about that
before right that's going
to be your anterior tibial
fibular ligament right
so again don't get
tricked up with the words
tibiofibular ligament
versus anterior talofibular
ligament you're also going
to have your posterior
superficial and deep
posterior superficial and deep
tibiofibular ligament
again tibiofibular ligament
and you're going to have
your intraosseous membrane
so again a high ankle
sprain is going to be
an injury to um to
any of these ligaments
So, the mechanism is
very, very similar to the
common lateral sprain,
although there's going
to be a rotational
component to the injury,
and we talked about
this in a prior lecture.
Basically, we talked
about LeBron James
injury, and we talked
about Patrick Mahomes.
We talked about the
Patrick Mahomes and the
LeBron James, very,
very similar where
the foot is forced into
external rotations.
So again the main thing is
you're going to have that
rotational component to
the injury. So diagnosis is
made by attempting to
mechanically separate the distal,
tibia, and the fibular.
So you're going to put a
stress on the stym dysmosis
and that's going to elicit
pain at the proximal ankle
joint. So I'll take a second
to think about what we
talked about. We're testing,
we talked about the test
for the high ankle sprain.
All right, so if you
were thinking about
the tibial talis shock
test, you are correct,
right? So the tibial
talis shock test,
right? Then the
external rotation
test is another one, right?
And then we talked
about the squeeze test
already, right? You're
going to put pressure at
the lower leg at the
mid-cap, at the mid-cap.
And then I have the
cross-leg test, right?
So we didn't talk
about the cross-leg
test, so we're going
to talk about that now.
the Pacers is going to
crest their leg with the
injured leg resting at
the mid-cap on the knee.
And here, look at this,
we have Patrick Mahomes,
right, so the force eversion
and external rotation,
right, you can kind of see
the motion as he's going down,
right, and he can't
really, he's in an awkward
position, he can't really
move, right, because
he's got a lot of
pressure from his opponent
putting down, the
pressure is going down.
So again, that's the
force external rotation.
So talking about the
testing, the cross leg
test, and again, you're
going to put the pressure
from the knee is
going to press up,
and it's going to put a
stress on the syndesmosis,
and that could be indicative
of a high ankle sprain.
And then we talked about
over here, we talked about
the force goes on the deltoid
ligaments and it's going
to go all the way up,
potentially to the fibular,
right, and that's going
to have a very fancy name.
If they do have a
fibular head fracture,
that's the mason-rube fracture.
Any ankle sprain
treated rice therapy,
right? So again, you're
going to see this
over and over again,
a lot of treatment.
Rest, ice,
compression, elevation.
You're going to put the
ice at the injury site.
You're going to put
them in a support brace.
Early range of motion,
right? You don't want to keep
them immobilized for too
long. functional mobilization
as tolerated, pain
medication as needed, and
don't forget OMM, this is
what you're training for.
And you're gonna have the
patient follow-up in four
to six weeks after the injury,
sooner if they need to.
Rehabilitation,
so proprioception.
You gotta retrain
the ankle and the
brain to work together,
so when you're
jumping up and they
land on the ground,
you want to make sure
that they're landing
on the ground where
they're not on
to invert the ankle
or e-vert the ankle,
right? So you got to do
some exercises that are
going to retrain the
brain to work together.
Proprioception, right, as
well as strengthening, right?
Strengthening the muscles
around the ankle, right?
To make it stronger, less
likely to become injured,
right? And then you can
also add support and taping,
right?
Incorporation of OMM,
right? So remember
the lower extremity,
the sympathetic to
the lower extremity
is going to be T11.
to L2, right? That's
your sympathetic
to your lower extremities.
You can also, so when
you do the rib raising,
you're going to want to
normalize the sympathetic,
right? So in order to
you're going to focus
more on T11 to L2, right?
When you treat, the
main goals are you're
going to improve the
restrictions, because
once you improve the
restriction, it makes it
a lot easier to improve
the lymphatic flow,
right? So you've fixed up
the restriction by opening
up the thoracic inlet,
doing some rib raising,
right? You're going
to improve on the
restriction, again, improve
on the lymphatic flow.
Lymphatic flow, when we
get down to the flow, we're
going to work on the pump,
right? So we talked about
many different pumps, the
thoracic pump. In this case,
if they can tolerate it,
you can do the pedal pump,
right, to improve the phatic
congestion of the ankle.
If there's a lot of
congestion behind
the knee, you can do
the popliteal release,
loosen up the fossa
behind the knee.
Again, rib raising,
so basically
improve restriction,
and it's going to
normalize the sympathetic,
and then you can add
some strong tissue,
paraspinal inhibition,
because you know that you
only have rib 1 to 12,
we don't have a rib at L1
and L2, so it's hard to
do, you can't really do
rib raising, so what are
you going to do? You can
do strong tissue, paraspinal
inhibition, so basically
you're doing strong
tissue right above L1 and
L2, because that's where
the sympathetic ganglia
is continuous to what
you have in the thoracic.
And just like you do
rib raising, right, here
you can do the paraspinal
muscles, right,
inhibition, and
basically you're putting
anterior direct pressure
on the back muscle,
the erector spinate,
and that's going to have
the same autonomic
effect as rib raising.
Right, so very, very simple
way to incorporate some
OMM into treating the
ankle sprain, the knee
sprain, and it's definitely
going to help the athletes
heal a lot faster, they're
going to appreciate
it, and you're going to
improve the lymphatic flow.
And that is the summary
slide, and so again,
history taking and
physical exam of the ankle
and the foot, you're going
to describe subjective,
objective finding,
normal versus abnormal,
I know the special
testing that we talked
about, we call the
appropriate way to document,
and then we incorporated all
of them into a case study.
So this is a summary
slide, definitely leave
feedback, let me know
how the lectures went. If
you have any questions,
you can always email me.
So like I promised in
the other lectures, I
know some of them went
over, I do apologize, But
this lecture, we went
under the hour, so we're
getting a little bit
closer to summer time.
So hopefully you all
enjoy the summer, but
if you have any
questions, let me know.
Otherwise, thank
you for watching.
Thank you for listening
to the presentation,
and we'll talk to
you soon. Take care.